les accusations de crimes de guerre en
ex rennes on y revient tout de suite
dans la revue de presse
avec wohlen frappe bien sûr bonjour
hélène bonjour pauline à la une de la
presse internationale l'émotion donc
toujours très vives après la découverte
de fosses communes dans des villages
ukrainien où l'armée russe s'est retiré
une femme à genoux pleurant son mari tué
dans la banlieue de kiev il y aura un
avant et un après butch annonce la croix
qui évoque de possibles crimes de guerre
et crimes contre l'humanité dont la
justice internationale aura pour mission
d'identifier les responsables qu'ils
soient militaires ou politiques
duch à irbine mais aussi au sto mail au
nord de la capitale ont été les
épicentres des exactions de l'armée
russe selon le figaro dont l'envoyé
spécial a interrogé une psychologue qui
dit avoir reçu des jeunes filles et des
femmes affirmant avoir été violées par
des militaires russes dans les
territoires qu'ils ont occupé des
histoires qui se ressemblent comme si
les russes avaient planifié tout cela
d'après caterina alliant tu d'abord le
matin ou l'après midi les soldats
vérifier qu'ils vivaient dans les
maisons puis il revenait le soir tu es
les hommes du foyer pillet l'argent et
les objets précieux mangeaient et
buvaient ce qu'ils trouvaient dans la
maison et quand il était saoul violer
les filles et les femmes racontent elles
trois patientes de caterina alliant âgés
de 16 17 et 20 ans ont presque
totalement perdu la parole raconte le
figaro certaines sont si choqué qu'elle
ne se souviennent plus de leur propre
nom mais en plus des traumatismes qui
bloque les souvenirs les mots il y a les
séquelles physiques les jeunes filles
que je prends ans que je prends en
charge non plus dedans
les russes leur ont cassé en plus de les
avoir violées raconte la psychologue
pourquoi par barbarie pur pour les
empêcher de parler je ne comprends pas
face à ces témoignages terrifiant hélène
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire les
appels à renforcer les sanctions contre
moscou se multiplient d'après le
chanteur m site l'appel des etats-unis
et de la france en faveur d'une escalade
significative des sanctions contre la
russie joe biden proposant un procès
pour crimes de guerre et emmanuel macron
demandant l'interdiction des
importations de pétrole et de charbon
russe le président français n'appelant
pas en revanche à une interdiction des
importations de gaz russe un qui reste
on le sait crucial pour l'italie
certains pays d'europe de l'est et
l'allemagne outre-rhin le gaz russe
continue de couler mais der spiegel fait
état d'une pression d'une résistante ce
grandissante contre cet état de fait
l'allemagne et d'autres pays de l'ue
veulent t'ils continuer à transférer des
centaines de millions d'euros par jour
vers la russie alors que le pays
poursuit sa guerre d'anéantissement de
l'ukraine interpelle le magazine
allemand la russie hélène dont beaucoup
de voix africaines défendent en revanche
la position et les actions en ukraine 1
mediapart rappelle que si 28 pays
africains ont voté pour la résolution de
l'onu condamnant l' invasion russe dix
sept se sont abstenus et 8 n'ont pas
pris part à ce vote une position qui
s'expliquerait par les liens historiques
de certains de ces pays avec moscou se
nouent et plus récemment autour de
partenariat militaire comme o malié en
république centrafricaine la tradition
de non alignement de certaines
diplomatie africaine ou encore des
formes de dépendance économique
le site d'info français évoque aussi
l'expression d'une détestation de
l'occident la poutine au filet d'une
partie des africains relèvent moins
d'une adhésion à la politique russe que
d'un rejet sur fond d' anticiper ria
l'isthme de l'europe et de l'occident
selon le chercheur camerounais paul
simon andy mediapart site aussi
l'analyse de rémy a décollé de
l'université de york au royaume uni sur
le fait que plusieurs dirigeants
africains espèrent peut-être s'y voir la
russie leur sauver la mise si leur
pouvoir venaient à être menacés
à l'image du régime du président bachar
el-assad en série toujours sur le
continent hélène l'armée mali indiqué
avoir éliminé à la fin du mois dernier
plus de 200 jihadistes dans la localité
de moura où des exactions auraient aussi
été commises selon plusieurs forces
sources locales du courrier
international relais les interrogations
de la presse africaine sur ce qui s'est
réellement passé dans ce petit village
du centre du mali on a envie d'applaudir
à tout rompre cette grandissime
illustration de la montée en puissance
des forces maliennes hélas amnesty
international la mission des nations
unies pour le mali et des témoins
expriment leur préoccupation si ce n'est
leur indignation après que les
militaires et leurs alliés russes ont
tiré dans le tas le jour de la foire du
village commente le quotidien burkinabè
l'observateur paalga qui estime que les
russes du groupe paramilitaire wagner
venus prêter main fort français à
l'armée malienne sont loin d'être blanc
comme neige et se demande si l'armée
malienne peut tenir en laisse je cite
les oursons cyber et là quelques mots de
la campagne pour la présidentielle ici
en france avec un coup de projecteur à
droite sur valérie pécresse dans un
entretien au figaro la candidate des
républicains répète ses critiques sur le
fait que cette campagne aurait été
volontairement escamoter le président
sortant a fui les débats et son scénario
cynique et être écrit al avance il veut
un face à face avec les extrêmes accuse
valérie pécresse qui se présente comme
la femme à abattre
merci beaucoup hélène c'était la revue
de presse on vous retrouve aux alentours
de 9h20 dans paris direct